in einer solchen Krise wird natürlich
das Vertrauen auf die Probe gestellt und
insofern ist es jetzt ganz wichtig
glaube ich dass dieses gehampelt was wir
jetzt hatten die jetzt Ampel gehabt
Ampel dass das jetzt mal zu Ende ist
das reicht natürlich hinten und vorne
nicht wie bereits gesagt habe weil sie
müssen sehen dass draußen die
der Mittelstand und die Industrie jeden
Tag kämpfen um den Erhalt der
Arbeitsplätze und es wird in jeden Tag
schwerer gemacht da hilft uns nun schon
und das schafft auch ein bisschen Ruhe
die Ansage dass der Deckel bei Gas auf
12 Euro sind festgesetzt wird und für
die Industrie auf 7 Euro Cent eigentlich
weil wie gesagt USA 3 Euro Cent oder
zwei Euro Cent und China 3 und gegen die
treten wir ja an
das hat schon geholfen nur wir müssen
natürlich wissen dass am Ende
wir nicht jedes Jahr 200 Milliarden auf
dem Tisch legen können das wird dieser
Staat nicht